tell me about your husband
ex-husband
he's a [ __ ]
george where you from where'd you grow
up
basically everywhere
i love the truckers
you had both your parents i
am my mother lost so she popped for his
back
excuse me cover break
is that your morning ritual
yeah yeah when did you start drinking
when i was 14 but my dad used to give me
beer when i was five and my mother
was like a pill hopper
so anyway to do go to the resident story
hello world i'm doris rollindelli here
to tell you
the facts
of something that you may want to know
and something maybe not
i'm homeless
go on living in the tenderloin in san
francisco
how long you've been down here number
nine tenderloin is a gift
20 years i've been here
you're living in a tent around the
street on the street on the street
yeah what's your drug alcohol alcohol
crab mess
money how do you support yourself
not sex work not anymore
i am
[Music]
kind of ashamed to say this you know
but i've been a preacher down since i
was 14. you've been what
a future dancer and a prostitute
since you were 14 this is where in reno
and i was a book dancer
and when did the harder drugs come into
your life
not that alcohol isn't a hard drug
19 14
to be honest it started with crack
how would you describe your childhood my
childhood
was hell i got
feed a lot
i really don't want to get into that
my childhood was there really wasn't one
i take it there was all kinds of abuse
sexual
physical verbal yeah
you don't need to get into it
how far did you go in school 11th
where'd you go after after that
i was still in reno
and i started writing about truckers
you have to forgive me man like less
than two weeks ago
i sleep on the street and i saw somebody
shot
that was like four feet away
you saw someone get shot
yeah the streets change at night don't
they yeah you get more dangerous
but it wasn't daylight it was during the
day yeah a lot
and folks i'm sorry i'm just
i've changed my choices in life and how
i live
and try to stay real through it
you have kids yeah
me about your children
um
i was married for 19 years
my husband was giving me to his friend
for math
my comes from his family
my mom paid for the brush dad picked a
man blah blah
and uh he called me [ __ ] in front of my
daughter
because i told him she they needed to go
to school
and i looked at her and i could never
turn back
it's been hell since that
really you still talk to your kids
i did like three years ago
my daughter vivian i love you brandon i
hope you're okay
michael i didn't get to meet
and we're all that cherished
that's pretty hard yeah
dear friends here today
friends like real friends not just
street acquaintances but
friends in your life
what emotions do you do you deal with
depression
i don't know but emotions so much but
you know
i know deep down inside of me and the
choices i make
is what i'm gonna suffer on makeup
what's your biggest regret how big is my
breast
no no what what is your biggest regret
buckets and bottles you know
i'm not gonna open up
my biggest regret is not being able to
be there for my children growing up
do you feel like you were loved as a
child but your your parents
at some time
do you have a cigarette i don't have a
cigarette
let me be honest i'm really sweating and
i'm like i'm really nervous to open up
but my childhood was basically
alone around the label to run
the real [ __ ]
uh
a lot was taken from me and choices
you know
when i fell into that
i found any depression i've been able to
succeed
you know and like really [ __ ] me up
when i was home 17 years
i went through a lot and uh
a lot of mental abuse
but the cool fact is
okay
i'm going to get caught up you know
do you blame the decisions you made for
where you're at today or do you blame
maybe
the way you were raised
the childhood you went through
none of that is not there
really none of it is sitting on there
people playing to that [ __ ] want to go
to recovery blaming them one day and cry
about it get over it but the true fact
is this
what you're going to do with your life
it [ __ ] hurts because my
husband killed
over 2.9 million and um
we married we found a law case
he called me home from my daughter like
i said i've been raped i've been
strangled
with like two things of liberating my
throat
i went with somebody
his dad was just senior worker
his dad would own it
i got tired of myself
and i started it
my best
is yet to come how old are you
i was born in 68
53 53 when i was married
i got back to my field i was going to be
an astronaut
so patricia powell and he had money and
everything so to be sorry called before
in front of my daughter i ended up
getting ready to strangle her in life
mostly beat down i was a dancer you know
what i'm saying it was
like taxi driver but
i don't want to change my life i just
want to live
i've had no chance for a place this day
i've had no help
what are you afraid of
what do you worry about
hmm
nothing
do you see yourself getting off the
streets and getting your life back
together
one day
let me tell you something about this
too many people want to get their lives
together that's all well and good
that might work for something
get down the streets at least you know
who you are
and your families
you feel betrayed by your family
gene mike what do you think anyway
no
i feel that they got robbed of each
other and happiness and
you know i've suffered missing
being kidnapped and
god how can i explain being married in a
mafia okay because i don't know a lot i
can say
tell me about your husband excellent
um
he's a [ __ ] he hit money
he didn't care about nothing but he
missed an addiction and turned into mine
and trying to use me on that and his
parents and
so
he's basically a good father and a
husband
and when he tried
was just run out brother's sickness
and his drinking and i started to drink
heavy
[Music]
99.
the best time my life was when me and
mike
were in the garage dancing
the worst is i don't know how to fight
for my life
i've never fought for my money
just like my stimulus is being ripped
i didn't want change
i want to change you know i mean
there's only so much you can sleep on
the street and be in your mean of fully
will
and being a part of everybody and family
but you also need some peace in your
life
do you have peace in your life
no is that why you drink and smoke
and i'm reading and i'm reading brain
isn't happening
do you still have help
as many people has helped me
and told me other stories
because the real hope is exactly my own
[ __ ] my own war
and stop being lazy on it
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
did i love god damn crap i'm sorry
the most important
balance that's a good one
do you have to come within you
you know
i really want to do something in life
i'm going to sing i'm going to dance
right modeled it
seen a lot
i'm not going to say this did he
say life isn't a whole lot of dogs
and it is not all money it is not what
risking or taking your life or being
away from your children
but sometimes people
fall into the trap of wanting to give
their kids everything
and wanting to do that or sell weed or
what are you really missing from your
life
i know it's hard but
damn
feeling at the situation paying bills
ain't the situation
mother [ __ ] has a chance
what else is left
are you at your bottom your lowest point
right now
well i got one hit left
yes and now
uh with some most
one day for a tent
into sleeping guys i heard it all
and that made my dreams come true
really yeah peace bumble
might have to rest
i feel like i failed the world by not
becoming what i wanted to
she's ready to talk about it
all right doris thank you so much for
sharing your story
i love you mark
doris you're beautiful thank you
thank you very much
i love the world i cherish the world and
god bless you all
and never forget life matters and so do
you
and each and every one
thank you doris go for your dreams
that was my grid
it's your beautiful speaker